ah my name is Oleg Sullivan and I'm
going to talk about finding memory leaks
and go programs and a little bit about
me I'm a software engineer elipse era
before that worked at VMware and cloud
foundry and Alcala found a boss which is
an orchestration tool and of course if
you want to follow me on Twitter there's
a handle and also up Sara adapt Sara
will do a lot of cool stuff and we are
hiring I had to say that sorry about
that
but what I'm going to be talking about
is memory leaks and go and go is a
garbage collected language I'm pretty
sure everyone knows it but you still
can't have memory leaks in it just as
you can with Java or Ruby or any other
garbage collected languages that you
have out there the good thing is go has
really nice idioms for resource
management such as the first okay okay
ah so garbage can language is still
prone to memory leaks just any other as
any other garbage graphic language out
there ah has really good idioms for
resource management first for example
and of course the rule of thumb is
always if anything is still reachable
from your protocol program it won't be
garbage collected
and by reachable I mean there's a
top-level object references and of
course the whole object graph that can
be reached from that will not be garbage
collected because potentially your
program might still use that and even
with all the resource management idioms
there might be problems such as the
first can be misused and I'll show you a
bit later how and acquired resources
might not be released properly
especially if you do something and then
library that you're calling out to does
something on your behalf like creating
new objects and doing something
and you do not ask it to destroy down
and the most interesting thing is it is
possible to use C with C go and then all
bets are essentially off because then
you can use malloc and when you use
malloc runtime can't help you so you
also have to use free as a rule of thumb
and I'm going to talk about several
examples how to take these leads and
very important thing to understand is
that even with code reviews and all the
good code hydrogen that you can
implement it all helps but some things
are still not obvious and really hard to
track and measuring and understanding
memory consumption is very important
fortunately go has a really good
profiler
it is built-in it is an calculate
centered library and bulky broth it's
easy to use and it actually helps a lot
in finding bottlenecks both in CPU and
keep profile and also when things are
detected no it doesn't usually happen
when you develop your thing and you
write some tests with five objects being
used or something like that it actually
happens to your production process that
they probably the least convenient time
in the real environment where you have a
very limited control over its execution
and that's where it's really nice to be
able to introspect what's actually going
on inside your life process and
understand how memory is being used how
CPU is being used actually what is going
on and let me start with this example I
hope you can see the goal here but it is
a pretty simple program that starts an
HTTP server and the very first thing it
does once it receives HTTP requests it
adds it to a queue of requests using a
buffered Channel and it responds back
but then there is a special goroutine
track request that processing of this
request queue and for each request in
the queue it creates a tracker and it
goes striker track and because they
create a tracker and needs to be closed
for example we also defer glows in this
tracker this looks pretty innocent but
actually
short function will not be called at all
sorry today at third master window I
will not be called at all because we do
in the loop and this work has a function
scope so when you call it a function and
it exits either normal or abnormally all
your diverse are going to be called that
at that moment but here because it never
exits or attacks
normal flow events these the first we'll
just keep accumulating and because each
defer keeps a closure so all the objects
that are reachable from this deferred
also be kept around and essentially the
reference StormTracker is also kept
forever in this one that's a toy example
so it's actually really easy to avoid
doing that by not using the for in this
particular case for example or by
implementing a function that you
immediately go out and do the for inside
is launched so when it's done
your deferred will actually fire and
everything will be alright but we can
say that because it's a it's a simple
program and it's easy to see but how how
would we prove it just using the built
in a profiling tools let's take a look
at and yes there's our problematic code
a cycle how we can find what's going on
but then we are going to use P prod I
don't know how many of you have heard
about B prof. it started out at Google
as a C++ profiler and it actually had it
is in go standard library as well and
it's very easy to instrument your
program to either have on demand
profiling or explicitly profile some
piece of code so with memory it is
interesting because as I said it usually
happens outside of it def cycle and you
want to be able to introspect the
writing process somewhere so your best
bet is probably to instrument your
program you
that HTTP paper off package and when you
start a CP server if you have this
import line in your in your go program
it will actually register a number of
handlers that will allow you to connect
to them and see what is going on
enable CPU profiling snapshots of your
profile or snapshot keep profile really
good thing about people off is that is a
sampling profile so what does mean for
memory profiling it means that only
tracks a small percentage of all the
allocations that your program is
performing so if people track every
location that would be really slow
because there needs to be some
instrumentation around each memory
location and that's that's not good so
what it does instead it just picks every
I guess one location maybe five hundred
thousand something like that and then it
approximates wheel count from these
something numbers which means that is
actually okay to use in production so we
do use it in production and there might
be some very insignificant overhead but
especially for memory profiling with how
many locations you have and with
sampling it's not really that pretty
good and you might want to run it on
some percentage of your servers if you
really care about squeezing the last bit
of performance from them but in general
it is and some of them it is completely
fine to run it and you can profile rank
process without affecting this behavior
which is really cool so it's one trick
you can use sof essentially on your
process and just grab for every board
that it leases on and then you will find
which board maybe by some trial and
error but you will find which board
profiles expose on because some servers
actually buy into port here and that
start their HTTP server on some
ephemeral port and that's where the
default multiplexer
also attach the big graph handlers and
you can use go tool P prof. command
comes with standard library you can
actually point it to your host on this
port which you either explicitly use in
your program for profiling or just found
out by introspecting Ryan crosses and if
you just run go to the broth and here
this path to debug people of heap URL
you can actually get into interactive
mode you can run some really interesting
commands which I'll show you a little
bit later but also important thing is
that you can take a snapshot of your hip
and save it locally and it's just a text
file that has some metrics about the
current hip usage and this way you can
actually get a snapshot and then come
back later and make a comparison this
way you can actually understand what
objects have accumulated in your program
over time and run several moves the base
mode which I just mentioned allows you
to compare your current profile with
some things which in mind snapshot ten
minutes before and then it is useful to
see what allocations are made over time
so instead of getting everything you'll
just get the everything going over like
the last ten minutes or something and
two interesting moves that hip profiling
with people have exposed is in use space
move it's when you want to see the
amount of memory that you use so it's
old although you're ranked by an actual
amount of memory that your objects are
allocating our your program is all gain
and then use objects will display a
number of objects that are currently
used by a program and this is what it
usually looks like so in this particular
invocation as an example of running
people off on some key profile which is
in ten current hip comparing it with
some base which we snapped
earlier using the Carroll command that I
showed you and eat you probably you
don't have to do it but if you provided
a path to your binary you can actually
and if you have source codes however an
interview as well you can also track it
back to the actual wines and source code
which are responsible for allocations in
your program so here they probably the
most use command in improv is Tom which
just shows you the top allocations in
this particular case it shows us in top
locations by by size so you can see that
there is a sound HTTP requests that are
taken some space and there's also main
track requests it also does some
allocations thing so how do I understand
what's going on
so in use objects is a another mode that
goes instead of showing how many how
much memory ok if you it will show you
how many objects I remember these counts
are approximate but their relative
distribution because it provides the
profiler sample in nature they are not
exact but their relative distribution is
probably about right so what do we what
can we do with it so so I just showed
you the top command then the least
command will actually drop it down in
your source code so you can see right
here in the try professed function the
trackers that we have allocating they
were not garbage collect because we took
the which will be based heap snapshot
and then we performed an incremental
profile and compared to snapshots you
see that the objects that were allocated
in between our exit trackers which means
trackers are allocated but not garbage
collected would question why so for that
web command we'll show you a splay will
display a profile graph in your web
browser which will give you this picture
so you can see the top offender here is
a red line header which is probably
where most okay
happen and go internet HTTP library for
work requests and numbers are really
important so forty four point five
percent of of 59 percent of allocations
have been in this method so we're going
to figure it out that's our request but
take a look on the right here lots of
the first also get accumulated which
means that they are not actually trigger
because we wouldn't see them they would
be garbage collected by now because we
took an incremental profile sunshine so
that's basically how for we're a toy
example that's how you figure out what's
going on and using the same tooling you
can actually apply it to a slightly more
complex programs so let me show a little
bit more complicated use case so here we
want to implement the request pattern on
top of pops up provided us to us by max
masses and master bus that we rolled it
up Sarah and from to use so it actually
has request pattern built in and it
doesn't have any leaks so it works
pretty well but for the purpose of this
presentation I decided to implement from
scratch so you can see the announced
request method here it just allocates a
new inbox for messages and subscribes to
all the messages that come to this inbox
then it tries a publish request to a
given subject and it expects to hear the
response ok these inbox that we just
created then waits for second for the
next message that comes in and when the
message comes in hand if it comes in it
just returns with the data that's been
stored in the response
it looks pretty innocent again but if
you actually run this program you will
see that over time if you just watch the
RSS of your process it will grow and why
is that that's where people comes to
help so if we perform exactly the same
incremental
shut up you keep over several minutes to
find your program you will see that a
lot of the time a lot of allocations
actually perform in the Nats connection
subscribe mention and if you run so yeah
we're just was located here and if you
run least from the P broth you will see
that subscription structure that Nath's
allocates to track every subscription we
create they don't get garbage collected
so we actually allocate about ten
thousands of them and they sort geared
we ran this problem which really means
they they're just staying around and
there's a round because we never
unsubscribe so if you remember what the
code looks like we subscribe we publish
requests we take the next message as a
response but substitution is still there
it sounded happens to publish the same
inbox that we used we will still get the
subscription come back also get fired
and we probably don't need it because we
just want one request so what would be
the correct thing to fix that of course
we can just defer unsubscribing from the
subscription that we just create as a
part of this function phone so the
reason we use the throw here is because
we don't really care if function panics
or if it finishes up normally or no
matter what happens we still won't
unsubscribe that's our invariant and if
you do that and we rerun the same
profiling we will see that this time if
you see this thing on the bottom they in
use objects for the incremental profile
comparison did not show us any objects
being new objects being allocated and
being still in use in between our people
of indications which means that we are
actually doing great job of garbage or
go runtime and actually doing great job
of garbage
everything that we have in our program
and if we're on on top on top if we're
on the broth with allocated objects
parameter we will see that actually
there's been a lot of object allocated
as we go it's just none of them are
action use they're all garbage collected
as long as they're not needed by your
program anymore and because you have
these two things it's actually helpful
to both find memory leaks and just
profile memory usage of your program
even if you don't leak anything we still
want to understand where your locations
go what objects you are using and what
are their sizes so there was a more
realistic example but people off is not
really a silver bullet so you can still
have memory leak if you see go and it
won't actually be detected so let's say
you want to use C standard library
directly from go and there is a way to
do that pretty easily with a single
there's a student package C which you
can use to actually go out to any C
standard library functions and this
particular use case we want to get our
user ID by by name and so that we use
get PW now system poll and because it's
a it's a C function it actually needs
some data that is prepared in a way that
C standard library can can use so right
here we L K the buffer with malloc and
we also get a C string which is very
different from go string for name of the
user and we actually we populate that
with a go string that we pass into the
function then we call out to the system
home and then we return the user ID that
we got from the system calls out the and
then we just have this in the loop so if
we run that we will see
stimulating memory however if we run
deeper on that we won't see anything
just because all these allocations are
not really tracked by profiling and
there there is no garbage collector that
will release this memory for us so
that's our problematic segment and in
order to fix it what we should do is
first we have malloc we should have free
with defer its will go with the various
actually you can probably say but now
it's my favorite but we're part of the
language but anyway with the fur you can
actually schedule your fries just when
you just in same place where you have
your mouth
so unlike C where you would have to
track and maybe some go to logic or
something like that to have different
snippets of time depending on which code
path you took here you can say hey no
matter what happens I want to deallocate
this buffer as soon as the function is
done
same thing with AC string that we
populated from go stream we will free it
and we're willing to do some massaging
by Pacific tag getting it to unsafe
pointer and that will allow us to get
rid of the memory but the problem is it
is really hard to detect it in the first
place so people off as I just mentioned
can't really help you will drink which
is a really popular tool for debugging
and profiling C programs also won't help
you because first it doesn't really run
would go out of the box and even if you
it is probably possible to run it with
go
but then runtime will actually stand in
your way and it will be really hard to
interpret results that movement gives
you just like with Java or Ruby that's
not super helpful for these highlighted
language again we need to sound good
roll with them to avoid situations like
that and one of them is if it's possible
it's better to make color to avoid
making color care about freeing memory
so if you need to allocate some memory
in your C go go okay it is better to
delegate
the same function call if it's possible
just so that no one else needs to think
about the Klingon logic for you and
again this is a trade off but if you
need to return manage go type from your
CEO forum you might consider using ghost
wink and go buy scalpers and it seems to
the package this will essentially copy
your data back into the world and then
it's all going to be garbage collected
but it's a trade out because it involves
some clapping and sometimes you might
want to introduce something as explicit
free method and then the color will be
responsible to calling for Cohen B's
free method at a particular point in
time so that is basically three examples
of how to introduce a memory league and
how to profile it and in general
profiling can help in a lot more ways
than just finding memory leaks pea
profiling helps you understand as I
mentioned memory allocations down done
by your program and see where they
happen providing an opportunity to
actually optimize and not just keep
profile actually CPU profiling is also
possible and with deep Roth it works in
exactly the same way so you can actually
it can make a profile that's 30 seconds
long profile of a CPU activity where you
can see the hotspots use top command
least command everything just to
understand better what's going on
actually the going blog post about
profiling go programs it's actually
highly mentions CPU profiling a lot
there's something about memory profiling
as well but much less than CPU so
definitely can see you're reading it
there's a lot of good information
on how to find hot spots many problems
also measuring is a way to go because
most trick non-trivial programs are
really hard to reason about so you need
to measure back to understand what
actually is going on and that's where
profiling is really helpful and one
thing that would be really nice to have
is like the Java for example you have
visual VM where you can actually go and
inspect your cape and see what objects
are actually on hip so as far as I know
in 1:3 the right hip down method has
been added - laughing - runtime package
where you can actually generate this hip
down but I don't know of any tools that
can actually take that and provide you
with a nice way of introspecting your
hip there might be some but if there are
none that's a good opportunity to maybe
for for fun hack hack project or
something and also one thing that is
very important as we're speaking of
memory is go memory model it's not just
about memory leaks but it is important
to understand that in order to avoid
situation and burn programs where you
don't you think it might seem that works
a particular way but it might not work
that way imagine if you have boolean
variable and then to go routines
actually try to act on that that might
not work because a good memory model
defines set of rules the port happens
after and happy and happens before
relationship between reads and writes
and different go routines and you should
definitely read if you if you're into
any serious goal line programming you
should definitely read the official
reference there's a link at the bottom
to understand go memory model and
understand where and you can have what
kind of explicit synchronization you
should have between different
things so that your rights and wand
origin will be visible by the reeds in a
different poverty and basically the
devil ate any questions
it's different
a musical
to profiling models so what
we don't know why as
yeah so the question is what profiling
is good but what tools you can use the
more into your memory consumption are
the metrics of your go problems so and
yeah but java is much easier because we
have JMX
you have visual vm you have all these
tools that allow you to enjoy spec the
program we go personally I haven't found
anything that would be actually useful
to introspect the state of the process
so usually you resort to extraordinary
by essentially making I know just seeing
how much memory overtime your process is
consuming and things like that but I
think with a break it down a dumb
addition in 1 3 I think there are some
steps in this direction so we might we
might get something hip inspection tools
so I hope so yeah so you can have
something like Nagios or something that
actually monitors your process
externally yeah but that would be no
different from monitoring prevent a
processor
or how many objects are on the side yes
yes so you can actually yeah there are
some stats that export by go runtime
which you can also track over time like
how many go routines you have what are
the different eight metrics and all that
stuff what would be really nice is to
actually have tools that consume that
and make it available in a really nice
way yeah like a sample agent for New
Relic to send an attack up it's like go
relic or something that's basically an
agent that I'll wrap that one time all
of GC information and maybe some CPU
routines end up to New Relic
and we don't use New Relic you might
want to look at that for some ideas if
you're looking for all in your room or
building something so yeah actually I
used to use New Relic for I think that
was probably project and like that was
pretty decent so event to do something
for go that's actually really good news
so you can probably use that for
collecting networks from your drawing
application to get more inside and
what's actually going on when you see
you say that you can do something
I guess Google uses finalizes mm-hm
documentation says roughly that you
should not use this for memory is all
safe is to use good manager
so I think these rappers that allow you
to convert between C data and go data
they actually make a copy so then we
don't really work with a with the
original date so they have to copy the
hope offer and then wrapped around the
go format and then your runtime will
finalizes yeah I think in general you
shouldn't trust finalizes because they
are almost never guaranteed to run when
you want them to arm so it could be a
nice strategy for potential cleanup just
if you want to do things right so saying
hey I actually want and when this object
gets delegated or destroyed by garbage
that I was I wanted Easter on but should
it be anything mission-critical just
like with Java or I don't think one time
gives you any guarantees on that yeah
some point this is compatible with a
like
ah I'm 100% sure I don't think it will
be because probably in sandbox you won't
be able to use it but I would definitely
try it out
who knows maybe it works I haven't tried
myself okay thank you